We were examining a Sparta,
they most uh,
important I think at the early polling,
certainly of the,
once you get into the seventh and sixth centuries,
and I was describing the formal constitution of the Spartans,
having mentioned the kings,
two of them and the Garrow Sia,
the Council of elders consisting of 28 elected men over 60 and the two kings to
create a body of 30.
Then there is the Spartan Assembly,
which consists of all the adult male spartan citizens and that as in most
states,
it really originated from the idea of having the fighting men participate in
decisions and the kinds of decisions that undoubtedly were the first decisions
the assemblies made.
And in the case of Sparta,
I would guess almost the only decisions they made were questions of whether to
go to war,
whether to make peace,
whether to make alliances and so forth.
Now it's worth mentioning that that assembly,
you want to distinguish that assembly from what I'll describe shortly about the
Athenian Assembly and this assembly.
It is true that all adult male Spartans were participants.
But,
and let me also say that they came to the meeting dressed in their military
uniform,
apparently including their shields because when a question was put to the
Spartans,
the way they responded was by shouting and banging on their shields were upon
the presiding official.
What,
try to determine which side had the loudest noise.
It's like a voice vote in one of our own meetings,
only a little bit more colorful.
And,
um,
and only of course if the,
uh,
presiding official decided that he couldn't tell which side had made the most
noise,
would they resort to a separation like,
like the British parliament,
uh,
those in favor over on that side,
those opposed on the other side and he would count and out would come the
result.
It looks as though debates in the assembly,
we're probably infrequent because as best we can figure it out,
we would guess that most issues that came before the assembly,
I mean,
back up and say probably not very many issues came before the assembly.
But those that did,
if there was an agreement,
uh,
on the part of the Garrou Sia and the kings,
in other words,
the upper groups in society,
if they agreed there would be no,
no need to go in.
There might be some legal need to go to the assembly,
but there would be no debate and the matter would simply go forward.
However,
some scholars go far too far in suggesting that there never was a debate in the
assembly.
There are debates reported to us into acidities,
which make it perfectly clear that they did.
But it is worth pointing out that so far as our information goes,
the only people who spoke at those assemblies with the Kings,
the Gev Rosia,
the um,
or a,
a group of people I haven't mentioned to you yet,
the fours,
the fives,
fours,
I'll describe their situation for you.
But for the moment,
they are annually elected officials of the state.
In short,
the average Athenee average spartan did not ever speak in the assembly.
It appears.
So it's not a democratic assembly,
even though every single citizen is there if he wants to be.
And,
um,
so that's part of the mixed and rabbit confusing aspect of the,
uh,
assembling.
Let me turn out to the floors.
These,
according to Spartan tradition were invented somewhat late in the development of
the Spartan Constitution.
The word f four comes from the word,
which means to oversee over to yes,
oversee what's going on.
They were in a certain sense,
the overseers and one of their duties was to,
uh,
keep watch on the kings and to see that the kings didn't do anything improper,
illegal irreligious or anything of that kind of a,
and some scholars have focused on that and suggested that at least originally
that was what their main function was to protect the Spartans from excessive
power,
excessive behavior by the kings.
Uh,
and that,
that there sort of watching the king's thing was always there chief function
that I think is not right.
I think by the time the Spartans appear to us in history,
let us say late in the sixth century,
fifth century,
um,
the efforts don't do that.
That's,
I mean they,
they still have to technical constitutional requirement to do that,
but that's not what they're up to when we see them.
They are usually engaged in dealing with foreign policy.
So if a neighboring state wants you to communicate something to the Spartans,
either it might be a offer of an alliance or it might be a,
uh,
an order to do something or else wore,
would follow or an negotiation for peace.
Any of those things.
First they would come to the efforts of which there were five and the efforts
would then decide what should be done.
I would say in most cases they would,
unless it was very,
very serious,
they would be able to give some sort of answer to it.
But when it involves something fundamental like war and peace or alliances,
then they would have to go to the assembly to get their approval.
But my guess is that it would have been wildly reckless and therefore never done
for the efforts not to go to the Garrow.
See at first,
because the gear was,
Sia,
was by far the most significant,
um,
council in the state most able to,
uh,
have the necessary prestige and yet to be small enough truly to discuss what
needed to be done.
And since the garrison area included the kings in involved the most important
people in the state.
So if the members want them to do something,
it would be damn foolish not to clear it with the Garcia first.
Although if they wished to be reckless,
they could do otherwise.
Now it's another thing about the efforts is that they're very different.
The people who are elected to the Garrow sia are old men who have proven
themselves.
They are truly elected by a process in which their individual qualities are
relevant.
And so they have tremendous prestige in the spartan state.
This is not true necessarily.
And the typically of the floors,
um,
Aristotle tells us that they in fact were just any Joe Spartan,
that they were ordinary people not distinguished in any way.
And although we don't have a clear picture of the way in which they were chosen,
it is clear that they were,
it was a con,
it's looked like it was some kind of a combination of election and sortition
there's a strong element of chance involved in selecting who is going to be the
effort.
So you must think of them not as distinguished people who have some clout in
their own person,
but ordinary people who only achieve what cloud they're going to have by virtue
of being chosen as efforts.
And they're only there for a year.
Now the kings are there for life and they get to see is there for life.
And I suppose the council at the assemblies there for life,
but the,
the,
uh,
efforts are only going to be,
um,
efforts for a year and only once in their life.
These are not politically powerful people.
I think the idea was to sort of have a representation of the ordinary spartan to
carry on the functions that I have talked about.
On the other hand,
they were given the responsibility of seeing that the kings were in line and
they had various,
uh,
techniques or various policies and processes which had them make judgements as
to whether the kings were doing anything wrong.
And if they did,
they could,
uh,
make that point.
They could go to Delphi and ask the God if they were right in thinking something
was wrong and if they came back that kings would be put on trial to trial.
The force would be the accusers.
The trial would be held in the Garrow Sia.
And don't imagine that that didn't matter.
Kings were brought to trial in this way frequently in the history of Sparta.
And very often they were convicted and often exile and in other ways punished.
So there's nothing,
just a theoretical about this capacity to control them.
And something rather important about this accidental element,
uh,
and who becomes an effort.
All right?
Those are the elements of the Spartan Constitution and I think it's self evident
that it deserves the title of a mixed constitution.
At the same time,
you don't want to lose sight of something even more basic than that.
Remember all the Spartiates that there are,
whether they are ordinary citizens all the way up through king are a small
minority of all the people who are under the control of the Spartans.
People try to guess from the evidence that we have,
what percentage of the entire population of the Peloponnesus or have their own
part of the Peloponnesus the Spartans work?
Well it looks as though the number of helocs may have been something like seven
hell lots to every spartan and then you have to add to that the number of Perio
Khoi who are also not Sparty aids.
So whatever the mixed character of the constitution was.
When you look at the whole of Laconia and its possessions,
it is very much an oligarchy.
And the Spartans normally we'll like to see other states oligarchic Lee govern.
They will not like to see either extreme.
They won't like democracies and they won't like any form of autocracy,
which in Greece typically took the form of tyranny and so the Spartans gain a
reputation of being because they often fight against tyrants.
They gained a reputation of being hostile to tyranny,
which brings our attention to the subject of foreign policy.
Very important for Sparta and for the Greek world because there's,
I think I mentioned before,
the Spartans became the first state to be in command or control or to be the
leaders of up coalition of states.
Not for a specific purpose only,
but a permanent coalition of states,
which the ancient Greeks referred to as the Spartans and their allies,
which modern scholars have come to call the Peloponnesian League and I guess I
will use that term and you'll see it all over the place.
It's an inn in precise term because some of the members of the,
of the,
I'm going to,
let me say a better term for it would be the Spartan Alliance,
which is what pretty much the Greeks called it because not everybody in the
Peloponnese was a member of the Peloponnesian League.
And now,
not every member of the league was in the Peloponnesus,
but still,
we all will know what we're talking about when we speak of the Peloponnesian
League.
Does.
I shall try to remember to speak of the Spartan alliance most of the time.
Well,
how did it come to exist?
Again,
as in most things in Greek history,
Eh,
the beginnings are shrouded in legend and are not absolutely clear,
but perhaps the place to start this to say maybe around 570 BC,
the Spartans who had been successful in apparently and turning around to some
considerable degree,
their defeat back in the seventh century by fight on August and we're expanding
their influence and power in the Peloponnesus suffered a defeat and the region
of Arcadia to the north of
Laconia.
Uh,
that by the way is,
is a mountainous country and it,
and poor typically relatively speaking and um,
it provided some of the toughest warriors in the Greek world.
So it's no miracle that the Spartans had a hard time up there.
And it looks as though it's at that point that somebody or somebodies in Sparta
came up with a bright idea,
which changed in that the nature of the Spartan situation.
And also,
uh,
introduce something new into the Greek world.
At the same time,
they,
they defeated the town of [inaudible],
which is located just to the north of Laconia.
It's a very important state for the Spartans,
not just because it's the neighbor right to the north of them,
but because you remember what I told you,
if you want to get to Messina from Sparta,
you can't go across those mountains.
You've got to go up north and then go left,
uh,
go west intimacy.
Enia Teggie is right there where the road turns west.
So its strategic importance is very great.
The Spartans got into this war with Ted ship and they gain control of Ted ship
where they,
uh,
claimed to have discovered the bones of the great Homeric hero Orestes and
taking it away from Tatcha the bones,
I mean,
and buried them at Sparta.
Also,
there was a legend that maybe they propagated that showed up in some poetry.
We have that Agamemnon had moved from his home base in my Sini to Sparta,
an attempt,
in other words,
to connect these Dorian Spartans with the legends of the great men of the ACC
Ian World described by homer.
And finally we are told late in the sixth century,
King [inaudible] who was one of the aggressive spartan rulers who expanded the
power of Sparta said on one occasion,
I am no Dorian,
I am an a Keyon.
What's this all about?
Well,
it looks like as the Spartans begin to extend this league that I will be telling
you about in a minute,
they want to make to reduce the amount of resistance that they're going to get
into.
Dorian's versus Akins still seems to have some meaning to the Greeks.
Remember the business about what happened in [inaudible] when the,
the tyrants of sicky on made this sharp distinction in favor of cans against
Dorian's.
It suggests that that uh,
division among the Greek people's hadn't died down yet and that's,
I think that's what's going on here.
Spartans are trying to claim union with the cans,
not dominance over them.
Anyway.
Um,
nonetheless the spark and start taking on other Greek states trying to establish
that domination and are very successful.
They defeated the powerful and important state of our gos.
They defeated,
uh,
I'm sorry.
And in the process they took away a piece of land that is between their area of
our ghosts and a Sparta.
The name of it is a Chi Noria and took it away and next to to their own state.
That's interesting because the are jives never forgave that and never gave up on
the idea of getting it back.
And you find the archives and the Spartans fighting each other at least once a
century.
And what they're fighting about is gaining control of [inaudible].
Uh,
it's common people referred to kind area as the Alsace Lorraine of the
Peloponnesus.
Everybody who doesn't have it wants it back between these two states.
Um,
and finally the Spartans also take the island just off the south eastern edge of
the Peloponnesus called Sithrah,
which gives them a good strategic base there as well.
So they are expanding.
Now what happens,
I'll,
I'll go back to Teggie of for a moment because that's the first case we hear.
It's the model when they defeat the tensions instead of simply and next thing
their territory subordinating the people are subjecting the people to Spartan
rule.
They do something different.
They offer the tensions and alliance,
the character of the alliance,
certainly in the full fledged history of the Spartan Alliance.
We can't be sure whether the words,
I'm going to speak to you now,
we're all there in the original oath to of the Spartans made their allies swear
but it was there by the end of the fifth century.
Anyway,
I think something like it either was in the Ortho was understood and that is the
state that was defeated,
said,
agreed to accept the leadership of Sparta and the word that's involved here is
hedging him head Jim,
oh Nia.
And the,
uh,
the leader is called a [inaudible] and that is something different from being
your master here at this spot days it's a little bit less or at least you want
it to seem that way and to have the same friends and enemies as the Spartans had
and to follow them wherever the Spartans should lead.
A short way of saying it was that they turned their foreign policy over to the
Spartans and um,
accepted their leadership in war.
What do they get?
An exchange one,
the Spartans didn't take away a land their land,
destroy their houses,
make them slaves or anything like that.
Besides that,
they also,
um,
provided them promise them and provided them protection against attack from
somebody else.
When the Peloponnesian League is in place,
one of its consequences for most of the time is the end of warfare between the
states inside the Peloponnesus.
At least that was the theoretical situation.
As we shall see,
it will be broken from time to time.
But still it's generally true.
So now what does this mean?
The Spartans have done something that is similar to what the Romans would do
centuries later and it really an enormous achievement if you can do it.
When you conquer people,
one of the problems you have is every state you conquer is potentially a
problem.
You have to rule it and that's going to take more soldiers and um,
you will have to do something with them.
You acquire responsibilities that are greater than they used to be.
But the point is,
normally you don't gain any fighting men.
Spartan way of doing it means you gain more troops for your arm.
When the Spartans go to their allies,
they [inaudible] want to go to war.
They tell them,
send the your allotment of troops to the place.
We tell you on the day,
we tell him that a lot men could well be two thirds of their arms of their army
and there they will go to where the Spartans want to go and the general of the
army overall will be a spartan and they will be fighting for a spartan purposes,
uh,
unless the Spartans have chosen to fight for their allies purposes.
But the Spartans now have increased their military strength enormously by the
invention of this new thing,
the Spartan alliance.
Now the debate continues to exist as to just what that alliance was really like
war the Spartans free to do anything that they liked in foreign affairs or did
they need to have the approval of their allies before going to war?
I'm talking now about a constitutional question rather than a reality question
and scholars batted around both ways.
My prejudices are that the league's constitution,
whatever it may have been,
it was less important than reality.
That is to say not all states in the spartan alliance with equal,
some were large and numerous and strong militarily.
Some where some part of that and also wealthy others.
And some were at some distance from Sparta.
Others we're a small,
weak,
poor and close to Sparta I would say.
And I think they hid the evidence will support this as a fact.
Whatever the theory may have been that the closer you were to Sparta,
the smaller you were that week or you were,
the more you did what the Spartans tones you,
how's that for a shock and vice versa.
The stronger,
the more distant,
the wealthier you were,
the more independent you were of the Spartans.
I would say much of the time,
most of the time people did what the Spartans wanted them to do.
But we have many occasions in which states refused to do so and even get in the
way of the Spartans.
Now I think the Spartans very often when they had to do something called a
meeting of the Spartan alliance,
consulted their allies.
But it's not necessarily true that they took a vote as to uh,
what the ally's thought.
Sometimes they did.
I think sometimes they didn't.
It all depended on the situation.
If you want your allies to come and fight with you,
it's better to have them do so willingly then under orders.
And so that we'll explain in my opinion,
some of the reasons for calling it a Peloponnesian League meeting.
Uh,
not necessarily that they were required to do so.
But I've given you a mixed,
uh,
and rather vague picture.
And I think that's the real picture.
I think you can't be very sure either because he,
because evidence doesn't allow us to be sure how the league was supposed to work
and how it really did work.
But I also think nobody could tell in advance how it was going to work.
Whatever they understood constitution was after all.
One of the most important things that a is involved in membership in the league
is that when the Spartans say,
I want you to come and fight with me for these purposes,
you come and you bring your army to do it.
But we have a period in [inaudible] account of the Peloponnesian war in which
important states like Corinth and Thebes among others as simply say no.
And when the Spartans say,
why aren't you doing what you're supposed to do?
They come up with a very nice cock and bull story supported by theoretically
religious motives.
Why they can't do what they're supposed to do.
And the Spartans have to put up with it.
There's nothing they can do about it.
So I think now that I've mentioned the constitutional technicalities,
I think the real thing to ask in each case is what are the realities of the
situation?
And by which I mean mainly questions of power that determine what's going to
happen.
Alright.
But by the end of the sixth century,
there is this spartan alliance and Sparta alone among the Greek states is a
hidden gem inal power and able to use,
uh,
by Greek standards,
a much vaster military force than the Greeks have ever known.
So that when the Persian wars come upon them,
there will be no hesitation and no doubt Greek league that will fight the
Persians will be led by the Spartans.
And so great.
Was there a respect that the in which they were hill,
that not only did they command the army's,
even though they had no navy and no naval tradition,
they were even put in charge of the fleet,
although they often had the brains to use other people who had more experience
to do the actual uh,
leading.
But Sparta is in this position and I think that's important.
Well,
let's step back a moment and take a look at the Spartan state as we've been
describing it and ask what is it that motivates the Spartans as a state,
first of all,
um,
in its foreign policy,
because as we shall see,
there's this remarkable thing that even though they are by far the strongest
military force among the Greeks,
they are more than usual reluctant to fight and they don't like to fight wars.
If they can avoid them,
especially,
they don't like to go any great distance to fight a war away from home.
And they don't like to fight for any long period of time if they have to be away
from home.
And the reasons for that are really what I want to make you see at the core of
it all,
according to the acidities,
it was the fear of the headlights.
It's not just that the [inaudible] were so numerous compared to the Spartans,
but I want to remind you again of the,
they're tremendous dissatisfaction with their situation.
Their backs may have been broken,
but their spirits were not.
They always were hoping to have a rebellion in which they could undo this
extraordinarily heavy burden that they carry.
And somehow,
in spite of the hundreds of years in which this has been going on,
they did not lose sight of their nationality,
of the fact that they were Messinians and that they were a people and that they
had to throw off spartan controlled of them if they possibly could.
And their feeling towards the Spartans were,
as you might expect,
there is a story of a rebellion.
I think I mentioned this to you earlier in the fall,
early in the fourth century in Sparta,
somebody is trying to stir up the,
uh,
the people against the Spartan government and he mentions to people he's trying
to enlist in his side the headlights.
He says,
who would gladly eat the Spartans Ra.
I think that's what you have to have in your mind.
If you want to understand what the Spartans think.
If we take our whole army,
leave town,
go three days,
March away,
how do we know we'll find anybody alive when we get back?
That's always on their minds and hell up rebellions.
Although they don't take place every day,
take place very sparsely,
but they keep happening so that the fear is never irrational to that is added
the permanent entity of our gos,
which never gives up.
The idea of returning to the great days of fight on with our gos as the dominant
state in the Peloponnesus.
And that means that the Spartans have to be defeated for that to happen.
And so the,
the archives,
uh,
combat the Spartans,
time after time,
good stretches in between because the Spartans always beat them and do great
harm so that it takes a long time for them to come back.
But that's,
they're there.
They don't go away.
It's a problem.
So the Spartans of course have a need of a collection of states that stand
between them and their potential enemies of whom the art jives are the most
important.
So you can look at the Peloponnesian League in general as an the way in which
the Spartans dealt with the danger they felt internally and externally.
Another element that the Spartans always worry about.
Remember why or the Spartan so successful
in numerically,
they aren't many,
uh,
enough to actually just defeat anybody by numbers.
It's because they are the best and why are they the best?
It's because of this training system,
these values,
this way of life that is the purely spartan.
Wait.
So there were always,
I would argue,
likely to be a majority at least of Spartans who are suspicious of and hostile
to any kind of change in internally,
certainly and externally because external things have internal implications.
They're always worried about corruption seeping into the spartan system.
Corruption normally has the concept of what money,
wealth behind it.
If money comes into the picture and people start being bought by it,
they will cease to be thinking the way good Spartans should think only of the
state,
but they will think of themselves and their wealth and so on.
And another thing that corrupts is the search for power beyond what is
appropriate in the spartan system.
You remember that incredible contradiction where everybody has a similar,
almost an equal,
uh,
but each one is at vying for honor,
which is not available universally to all.
And so that means if you are a conservative spartan and the two words are
practically the same,
you're going to be worrying about that.
And that leads to conservatism in foreign policy.
War is going,
if you win,
you're going to have booty loot of some kind.
We'll come back into spark.
Moreover,
some people will gain reputations because of their fighting in the battle.
We'll bring them excessive honor will fill their heads with a sense of their own
greatness and again,
threaten the stability of the Spartan state.
So all of that is going to explain why the paradox of the greatest military
power in the Greek world reluctant to fight,
uh,
and their power is not used to acquire economic benefits.
Uh,
what they focus on is discipline and the state versus freedom,
individuality,
and even family.
There you have this strange society,
a closed society that does not normally permit people to come and visit Sparta.
And even those that it permits to come to Sparta during one period of the year,
they actually force all farmers out of town and uh,
do whatever strange things they do.
And now when we're talking about the fully developed Spartan state,
there are no exercises of the arts such as existed before this system was
created.
There are no luxuries legally in Sparta.
There are few creature conference.
Again,
I suspect that some fairly early time there were violations of these things is
individuals who had the power to do so,
might well try to enjoy these things in spite of their being barred.
But the main thing is you couldn't,
if you had and you couldn't really show him,
you couldn't flaunt it because,
uh,
that would be disastrous.
And why?
Because in a way,
in necessity becomes a virtue.
We human beings,
that's one of our typical ways of dealing with things.
That is we need to do something.
We have to.
And so one way we cope is to then we do it and we say it's the greatest thing in
the world to do and doing anything else has no good.
Uh,
and that's what the Spartans did.
Their way of life was imposed upon them by the decision to maintain their
command of the hell outs.
After that,
it all makes perfect sense.
Look what they had to give up to do it.
They said,
of course we give that out because that's what makes us the great people we are.
And that's the system that was the spartan way of life.
Um,
I would remind you again that even though this is very extreme and other Greek
states are not going to live that way,
they admire it tremendously because it suits the ideology of all police that
subordinates individual family concerns to those of the community at large.
And as I mentioned earlier,
um,
the Utopian philosophers of the fourth century,
Plato being the most striking Aristotle to a lesser degree,
they had Meyer this,
although they have their own wrinkles about how it's going to be,
nothing could be greater as a contrast to this way of thinking than the way that
the Athenians will develop when they go through their growth as the Polis.
And so let's take a look now at athletes to see how they came along.
Here we go.
Athens,
I hope you'll remember from your maps is located in the south eastern portion of
the Greek peninsula sticks out there into the GNC.
It's geography.
It's about a thousand square miles is Attica.
And the terminology,
I think we talked about it already.
The city is Athens.
The uh,
um,
the,
the region in which they live is Attica.
The people are Athenians.
And that's an important point I think I made too,
which is everybody who is a citizen who lives in Attica isn't Athenian.
No matter if he live 65 or 70 miles away from the city,
he's still an Athenian.
One of the things they achieve early was the unification of that whole region,
uh,
and make it made it one polis.
Although that certainly doesn't mean that there are no independent villages and
towns in the polis of acids because they certainly are now,
Attica was not one of the most desirable,
certainly agriculturally rich areas in Greece.
It was relatively speaking,
rather baron.
Now there are of course a great exceptions.
The central valley,
so to speak,
of Attica,
has the richest soil and in the ancient world it was able to grow the very best
grain,
including wheat.
But very much of the Athenian soil is mountainous and pretty close to Barron so
that you don't have a lot of rich soil.
This is not one of the most admirable places to come.
On the other hand,
it has certain advantages that the Athenians used well to achieve wealth and
power and greatness.
First of all,
it has one splendid harbor up in the north.
Western part of Attica is piracy.
It is the port of a attic of Athens.
Once absence becomes a naval state and it is both spacious,
it has a three nice little harbors and it is very easily defended because these
harbors can be closed off and the tax can be prevented.
So that's one strength.
Another is that very rare among Greek states,
Attica contained silver mines in the south of the peninsula.
And that gave the,
because these mines were ultimately owned by the state,
it gave the state a source of income that was very,
very unusual among the Greek city states.
And will,
the availability of that silver would turn out to be crucial at various moments
in Athenian history.
One reason why the soil wasn't so great for agriculture was at a lot of it is
red clay,
but that turns out to be wonderful for making pottery.
And of course Athenian pottery.
And I'm thinking,
especially about,
uh,
painted pottery fine,
where stuff that is meant for the upper classes,
stuff that you,
artists we'll work on that will be exported,
all of that that is made of that great red clay.
The basis for the,
um,
pottery that the Athenians did,
another natural resource of great value and a great blessing to those of us who
can still see the remains of the Athenian experience is the marble that comes
from Mt.
Penn telly,
as the Greeks call it now,
Penn Deli,
Penn telecon as the ancient Greeks called it,
um,
in the northeast portion of the,
uh,
attic peninsula and it produces,
you can still go see it.
Wonderful,
beautiful,
fine,
green,
white marble.
And that's the stuff that the Parthenon and all the other buildings,
temples on the Acropolis and around Attica was made of.
And that enabled the,
uh,
the Athenians to build those temples as few cities could because there it was
sitting in their territory,
not a source of the kind of tremendous expense it would be for other states that
would have to buy it and bring it in.
Now,
on the other hand,
Athens was able,
as I told you,
well let's start in the early days to grow wheat and other grains,
but more to the point,
it was very good for olive trees and for grape vines.
So as we will see,
when the Spa Athenians begin to exploit all of their land,
not just the bottom land that works for grain,
but also the,
uh,
less desirable land and produced wine and olive oil,
that was a source of agricultural wealth that would play an important part in
their history.
Now,
their own story about their past was something like this.
They,
unlike the other inhabitants of southern Greece,
according to their story,
never experienced a Dorian invasion.
Now the
Dorians did come down and sort of bang at the door of the Athens Attica,
but they were driven off by the Athenians and never made their way into it.
So the Athenians claimed that they were in a certain sense,
the purest of the pure Greeks.
And they went to great lengths.
One of his stories,
claims they were,
as the Greek word goes on top,
so no status to say they were,
they sprang from their own soil.
In fact,
they said they were in Attica before the creation of the moon.
I guess you don't have to believe that.
But on the other hand it's their picture.
We were always here.
The original indigenous people,
their tradition and sure this one is surely right,
is that at an early time in their history,
they Attica became a refuge for people escaping what they would have regarded as
the Dorian invasion.
And there's no doubt that people from the Peloponnesus in there after the fall
of the Bronze Age,
civilizations did a lot of running away and some of them ran to Attica and what
greeted and settled down there permanently and some of the most important and
um,
most hours Socratic Athenians trace their ancestry not to the Athenian.
So were there before the moon was created,
but the people who had come in this a flight sometime after the end of the
bronze age,
it is a tradition of producing conflict.
But if producing harmony,
these exiles we are told were brought into the Athenian people and lived among
them as Athenians,
no split,
no division.
Similarly,
there is nothing like the hell on class and Sparta and Athens,
they're on those servers.
There is no suppressed population waiting to get at their rulers.
So that there's a kind of a historical good fortune which says Athens is going
to be without internal strife,
I don't mean totally,
but to a great degree compared to their allies,
uh,
to their,
to the other Greek states.
Now,
one important example of what happens in Athens,
it doesn't happen other states is this,
there's a tradition in Athens of an event called Sin Oil Kiz Moss.
It's on the,
uh,
on the site.
So you can look it up,
which means unification.
It really take,
if you take the word,
it means
the bringing of households together.
There is no set of local rebellions against the major city.
No need to go to war.
Now,
there were obviously at wars back there in the early days of the,
uh,
um,
Paul when the,
uh,
the city of Athens became the dominant city.
But it's,
we know so little about them.
It's as though the memory has been entirely forgotten.
And the picture that is painted is one of,
uh,
everybody sort of happily living together.
Uh,
no,
no conflict.
Compare that to Sparta where it's obvious part of gain control of the
Peloponnesus through war and that many of the people there were very unhappy
with them.
Not to mention the Hellos,
but in neighboring be Osha.
The chief city of Thebes
traditionally was at war trying to subdue the other major cities of be Osha in
order to make themselves the boss.
And they never were fully successful in this.
So be Osha is torn to some degree by this internal conflict,
which makes it harder for thieves to achieve the kind of power in its own home
territory that the Athenians are able
to achieve.
Um,
let's take a look at the earliest society of Athens as first we come to know
him.
Warning about this is that the story often comes to us through people like
Aristotle who liked to make things neater,
uh,
and put them in nicely together rather than,
um,
to leave a little bumps or anything like that.
The society we're talking about this earliest society is arrows,
Socratic.
And remember,
it's important to notice the difference between aristocratic and Oligarchic as
Socratic implies rule,
I mean means rule by the best and best in that time means simply best by birth.
Just look at it.
Excuse me a second.
No chairs today.
Huh?
Let me,
my back is hurting me.
you got care.
Oh,
thanks Chris.
We appreciate that.
Thanks a lot.
Okay,
I'll try to speak loud.
You can me in the back.
All right,
good.
That's much better.
Um,
it means the best by birth.
And that means if you're going to be in the ruling group and the dominant group
and Aristocrat,
the only way to get there is if your father was an aristocrat.
Doesn't matter how rich you are,
doesn't matter what a magnificent warrior you are.
All that matters is birth.
And that is different from oligarchy,
which gives rule to a few.
But that usually means I would say just about every case that wealth plays a
role that you can be one of the few in the ruling group if you're rich enough.
I don't mean that they didn't have aristocrats within an oligarchy.
I'm sure that they did.
It's that that was not the uh,
critical element.
Now also in the Athenian aristocracy,
you can imagine that most aristocrats are rich,
but some of them are not.
And uh,
that's the distinction that matters.
And we will come back to that point as we see Athens move out of the
aristocratic condition and into one that is more based on wealth than it is
merely on birth.
Well,
we are told that in the earliest times Athens was divided up the people of
Athens who are divided up into four tribes just as were all the other Ionian
cities.
And the Athenians,
of course we're Ionians.
This is a point worth making because most Ionians lived on the coast of Asia
minor or on the islands of the Aegean.
And the Athenians were pretty much,
I'm exaggerating,
but mostly the only Ionians on the mainland.
They sort of were an interesting middling group between the Dorians of the
Peloponnesus and the Greeks of other types elsewhere.
And the Athenians sort of stood between the mainland where they existed with a
boar and the,
uh,
the islands and the across the seas.
Um,
each one of these for traditional tribes contained according to this tradition,
three subdivisions that we'll called frat trees.
Easy way to translate factory is brotherhood.
Notice it's all,
again,
it's about family and birth.
You are in a fractory,
you're in that frat tree because so was your father and it inherits it.
But these frat trees were very important.
I should have mentioned that the tribes had important religious functions
that also the army consisted of four regiments,
one for each tribe.
So these tribes had great reality for the Spartans.
You went not only to the religious festivals of the entire state,
but you went to those only for your fellow tribesmen,
which gave you a sense of belonging in that tribe.
And I think that's important.
And the frat trees were smaller versions of the same thing.
Frat trees had religious rights of their own and in fact the fracture,
he appears to have been
the unit that really mattered in terms of the place where you sort of
established your belonging.
I mean,
if somebody came along to an Athenian in the seventh century and said,
you say you're in a Fenian,
how do I know you're an Athenian?
Well,
after you've got through saying,
well,
you can ask my friends,
my neighbors,
he have,
what did they know?
You said,
how would you do it?
Well,
I guess it come down to a meeting of my frat tree.
They will have a record of my being a member of that flattery and that makes me
an Athenian.
So that's uh,
the importance of,
uh,
in a way,
a one part of the importance of the frat tree.
Now the Frat tree,
because it was established by birth and tradition was an aristocratic stronghold
everywhere.
You could imagine tribe,
frat tree and so on.
Some aristocratic family or families would have had a leading role by tradition.
The Greek religion didn't have priests but it didn't have a separate priestly
class and during the aristocratic period,
and I would say probably throughout its history,
Athenian religion had the th the priesthoods,
the chief religious places in the state.
We're held by aristocrats,
which in a primitive society in itself gives them tremendous prestige and a lot
of cloud probably,
although I'm not sure we have hard evidence on this.
Probably the factories fought side by side in the tribal regiments as well and
of course they would always be commanded by heiress to Craddick leaders.
Another way the Athenian people were divided involved names of classes of
people,
and we'll come back to that in another context,
but one class,
the highest class in the Iris,
Socratic State Worthy you Patrick [inaudible].
It means the well barn,
the well sire and it turns out that in the early Polis,
no surprise they dominated the best farm land they had the chief jobs in
religion.
They were the government because as early as we can tell that there was a regime
after the legendary king's are gone,
the number one governmental organization you might call it is the counsel of the
Reo.
Pagus gets its name from the place where it meets.
If you look to the west side of the Acropolis,
immediately there's a pretty good sized hill,
which is the area because the hill of Aries,
the war got there,
the council of the area because MIT and did what it had to do and it's clear
that the members of the area,
because in this earliest stage we're nobleman.
We don't know enough to know whether it was all noblemen or just the leaders of
the clans or whatever,
but that's where decisions were made.
It's important though to realize that in these early days of the Polis they
probably had very little to decide and very little to do.
Most of the real life of the,
of the state in the earliest days would have been out in the countryside where
the overwhelming majority of the people lived.
You must imagine that it's as something like nothing like precisely,
but something like the,
a feudal,
uh,
manners that we find in western Europe after the fall of the Roman empire.
These noblemen would typically have heart led,
held a lot of land and have been well to do,
have had all the powers I've described and we'll looked up to and we'll listen
to,
they would have led the military units into battle when that was necessary.
And we know that one of the things that they did was to serve as the source of
justice in the state.
If there was a quarrel between a couple of guys,
they would bring it to a court that you think of easy.
It,
his complaints were his,
his noblemen,
his barons were a crooked,
but that doesn't mean they all were in any case,
that's where you went.
They settled any disputes that you didn't settle by feud or by some other
primitive technique.
And it was pretty clear that they were,
it was right to have the nobleman do it.
Not just because they're aristocrats,
but because they would know what the law was.
Since there was no writing before the eighth century and it was very rare after
that,
there was nothing like a written law code until the seventh century.
Before that,
if you want to get justice,
you went to a nobleman and if you wanted to go beyond that,
you went to the [inaudible],
which was made of nobleman.
That's the picture in the earliest policies.
Best weekend,
reconstruct it.
Now.
Aristotle tells us that beginning in the early seventh century,
the date he gives us,
we of course we shouldn't put too much credence in it.
It's too precise,
but it's six 83 BC is the date he gives us and he tells us in that on that
occasion we are introduced to a new thing,
magistrates who are chosen from the aristocracy to do various jobs in the city.
In Greek,
in Athens.
The magistrates were called our cons arc,
h.
O.
N.
S.
It means in the most technical sense rulers,
but it means really,
uh,
important magistrates in the state.
One of these was called the war.
Our Con Paula mark,
presumably he led the army.
Next came the art Kahn who was actually the most important art con,
the one who gave his name to the year if they,
I think I mentioned the Greeks did not have a system of dating which has a
starting point.
And so you can say one,
two,
three,
four,
five instead,
like many ancient peoples,
they named the year after the leading our con,
the leading magistrate of the state,
the Mesopotamian cities did the same thing.
So that our con was called the art con upon him was the one who gives his name
to the state.
And uh,
so if you wanted to know when did a thing happen,
somebody was saying it was in the art con ship of so and so and so and so.
Well you wouldn't have that in your head.
You'd have to go someplace and look it up where there was a list of our cons
anyway.
He was the most important.
A third art con was known as the king,
our con,
the arc cone.
[inaudible].
His responsibilities were mainly religious
and uh,
but I should point out that all the are cons,
whatever else they did,
everyone them also did justice.
That is they had courts to which people could come to get their quarrels
settled.
Sometime after that,
after these three major figures that I have mentioned to you,
there was uh,
established a body of men called Fez Mutha tie.
You'll see on the list of words
which weren't six men whose functions whereas apparently strictly judicial,
they held,
they,
they sort of held,
presided over courts that you could go to for a specified pur,
uh,
purposes.
Every one of these nine archives,
they are sometimes referred to as the college of nine are cons.
They had a secretary which would have brought them up to 10,
but only nine with true art cons.
They were elected by,
I'm sorry,
from the aristocracy,
by the assembly of all Athenian adult males.
That means,
uh,
mainly not aristocrats they chose from among the aristocrats for these are cons
who served for one year and not again,
that's a very important concept.
Nobody in Athens holes in office at this time where I far as I can tell for any
at any time.
Well,
I back up at this time,
um,
for more than a year.
The only thing in town that has continuity that can develop power and influence
over a period of time is the council of the area Pikas and that's what
aristocratic and oligarchic regimes do.
They are very nervous about individuals who acquire too much power,
popularity,
influence,
which will threaten the character of the aristocracy.
Aristocracies it's,
this may seem funny,
but aristocracies love equality,
equality among aristocrats and then tr tremendous inequality,
uh,
between them and everybody else sort of the way Yalies feel about things.
Really.
Gail is a very nervous about anybody sticking his head up above the crowd
because,
you know,
it's like,
uh,
the question always is,
why not me?
You have high expectations of yourself.
And so sometimes unless you're invaded by a later religious ideas that the
Greeks didn't have,
uh,
you're,
you're not humble.
You,
you're vying for honors.
I always see Greeks in front of me when I see Yalies
and aristocratic republic is what we have,
not a monarchy but a republic dominated in so far as it's dominated by anybody
but individually aristocrats by the area office and at some point in the history
of that institution it becomes,
it consists now of men who have been our con the year after there are cons ship,
they automatically go into the area,
ah,
pagus and remain area opera giants for life.
Well that gives the council of the area because even more power because an
influence,
because they consist now exclusively after awhile of people who have been chosen
for their individual qualities to be the leading magistrates in the state.
And now they will oversee what's going on and you can bet they will be looking
very carefully over the shoulders of the aristocratic are cons whenever they are
in power to see that they're not screwing up,
but also to see that they are not getting too mighty and too powerful.
The weight of the power of the area,
ah,
pagus must have been enormous in this system.
So the rich and the well born because they are pretty much the same in the early
days of the Polis,
run the state in this official constitutional way.
But I would also remind you that on their estates out there in the country,
they run the thing just as well with the farmers and everybody else out there,
cal telling to them and seeking their favor.
That's the kind of world that we have at the start
and then it comes to Athens as a did to every other Greek state.
Little bit later it looks like in Athens,
all of the change and turmoil that we've seen in our gos in current and other
places,
if we are right in talking about something like a hoplite revolution,
it occurs in Athens to,
and Athens grows slowly and again late,
but it begins to engage in commerce to a greater degree than before and in
ancient handcrafted manufacturing
and it just as it does elsewhere,
it leads to new wealth and new class distinctions which are now based not on
birth but on wealth.
And we hear new terms,
not all of them knew.
A couple of them knew that come into the picture.
We hear about Athenians divided into different classes.
Excuse me.
One of these you remember was the,
uh,
you patch a dye the wellbore.
And that's the old story.
And there really were only to those who were in those who weren't.
But now we hear about people called hip pace and it means horseman.
Cavalryman well,
you can't own a horse and ride a horse unless you have a lot of money.
Horses are expensive.
So there are rich people who are these carrier?
Well,
if they've had cavalry in the past,
they've always been aristocrats.
But what we'll see in the future is that there will be men who are hip pace,
who are not necessarily aristocrats at the bottom of the barrel.
We hear about people called feats,
They've,
they've always been around.
They are the poor.
They don't own land.
They are,
uh,
they live at the mercy of chance.
They work for other people.
They do anything they can to stay alive.
But now comes the new thing.
People called zoo get Tai,
What does it mean?
It means yoke fellows.
Now there are two senses of the word yoke that seems to be in evolved in this.
You could say that,
and this is one way that makes sense.
These were men who were sufficiently well off that they could own a team of
oxen,
two oxen who are yoked together to pull the plow that would make them
respectably well off farmers.
We are talking about people of the hoplite and class.
Another theory is that they were indeed named that because they were hoplites
because they lined up in the Phalanx and they were yolked together,
so to speak,
by their shields touching one another.
It hardly matters which of the stories you prefer or whether you choose both
were talking about the same people.
And that tells us the important fact that this new class of independent family
farmer has arrived in Athens and as in other states is not satisfied with his
position in the state as his own importance to the state becomes greater and
greater.
We will come back to this story when we talk about so long,
but think about these changes is happening as the next change that I want to
tell you about occurs.
Uh,
change,
uh,
that threaten or a change.
It didn't happen,
but if it had,
would it changed the entire course of events according to tradition in the year
six 32 and a fenian nobleman who was,
had become famous because of his victory in an athletic contest and who had
married the daughter of a very wealthy and powerful tyrant in mega right next
door to Attica.
So this guy was a young,
big shot of extraordinary,
a character named Kylon attempted a coup d'etat,
trying to establish a tyranny in Athens just as his father in law had
established one in mega.
His father in law's name was Thea journeys.
Well,
as the story goes,
he tried his best to gain control of the city.
What you do in Athens in the early days,
if you want to take control of the city,
is you take an armed force up onto the crop.
The Acropolis sees the Acropolis,
make it your fortress and proclaim yourself boss and see if you can make it
stick.
Well,
he couldn't.
He was resisted by enough of his opponents that he was defeated.
The leader of the resistance was the family known as the alk me on a die.
We will hear a lot about them in this course,
but they went up there,
locked up Kylon and his supporters in on the Acropolis in a temple.
You couldn't go in and to the temple for the purpose of killing somebody.
That would be sacrilegious and so they were at a standstill.
Still if you're inside that temple in trying to avoid being killed,
you still need food and drink and most important drink.
So how could they manage it?
Well,
they took a cord,
tied it to the temple,
held onto the cord and went down to the well and got their water,
claiming that they were just as sacrosanct as they had been before.
And for a while it worked.
But the Aquion [inaudible],
he said,
Bologna cut the cord killed the colonias.
That put an end to the colonian conspiracy,
but it brought something to the Aqua Miana die as well.
A curse.
The alchemy and eds with declared a cursed and driven from the city.
Well,
that's for the time being.
Later on we will see here they're back again and they're very important.
But the curse continues to be attached to the family.
And as we get to the last end of the last third of the fifth century and the
Peloponnesian war is about to break out the enemies of Paris,
please,
we'll pull out the curse of the Alcmi on a diet to use against them because his
mother was of the alchemy in had family for the moment.
What we're talking about here I think though is here's the first sign that we
see of trouble in paradise.
Nice,
calm,
happy [inaudible] Athens has got trouble right here in river city.
I mean no in athletes.
And
uh,
why I think we must imagine that there are the kinds of discontents that we have
been talking about,
which find the leader in the form of a man who was an outstanding figure for
some reason,
who was willing to try to establish a tyranny and,
uh,
use armed force to try to achieve their goals that it fails,
I think is an indication that it,
that the same forces haven't reached the power in Athens that they had reached
in Mega,
uh,
current sicky on and places like that.
But it,
it's a warning about troubles ahead.
And I'll turn to those,
uh,
troubles in the next hour.